salut quand j'ai lancé le mental blog je
me suis dit tout le monde sait ce que
c'est le mentaliste tout le monde sait
ce qu'est un mentaliste je me suis
aperçu que ce n'était pas forcément le
cas du coup lundi je vous ai posé la
question sur facebook pour vous qu'est
ce qu'un mentalist j'ai lu toutes vos
réponses sur les deux facebook vous avez
été très nombreux et très nombreuses à
répondre et vos réponses étaient
surprenantes lire dans les pensées des
autres images très classique quelqu'un
qui puisse lire toutes les émotions et
les pensées un classique propose tiffany
tiffany que vous avez vues dans deux
vidéos d'ailleurs manipulation pour
coucher avec une femme évidemment alors
là c'est drôle féodaux une fille qui dit
que mental et c'est quelqu'un qui va te
manipuler pour coucher avec toi donc
selon toi l'alcool est un mentaliste
haute du coup à chaque fois que tu fais
une soirée et que tu ramènes le mauvais
mec à la maison le lendemain tu dis non
mais attends à tous les coups il était
mentaliste en fait ce qui est étrange
c'est que je pensais que c'était un
fantasme de mecs mais marie te dis la
même chose manipulation pour draguer
matin une femme sur son lit en plus à
chaque fois c'est pas juste pour draguer
c'est pour coucher il ya une vraie
finalité je rigole mais marie avait une
autre hypothèse beaucoup plus
valorisante
il existe sûrement des mentalistes
vengeur qui tue tous les gens qui m'ont
ce qui est terrible c'est que je prends
tous ces commentaires là pour moi parce
que je me dis quand vous avez commencé à
regarder les vidéos c'est les clichés
vous aviez sur les mentalistes parce qu
un mentaliste qui cherchent ce à quoi il
pensait c'est un schizo cette phrase est
beaucoup trop dur à lire selon moi le
groupe de mots les mentalistes cachent
deux qualités essentielles d'un
mentaliste
en effet à travers ce groupe de mots on
peut dominer les mentale une liste les
mentale et liste à part rendront tout le
monde trouve ça normal
on peut faire référence à l'est mental
car l inverse de celui ci le mentaliste
n'a jamais de trous de mémoire
ça c'est de la vanne ludivine le pire
c'est que ça me fasse rire c'est la
conversation vous avez lancé sur ce
sujet certains diraient que c'est
physique comme raisonnement en tout cas
grâce à toi en ce sens et payer une
bonne tranche le mentalist fait fondre
les certitudes les mentalistes doit se
méfier des rappeurs plus de celle ci
fabien fait partie du gratin du
mentalist
nous ne parlerons pas de souci ça suffit
j'arrête oui je t'en supplie arrêt on
peut compter sur les mentalistes pour
savoir si mozart est là
où cette fois c'est vraiment fini ce nom
je m'arrêterai plus wii ne le relance
est pas en fait si j'avais eu le temps
de faire un montage aurait trouvé ta
photo tanguy je dors et fais parler avec
les lèvres et à la fin j'aurais mis
l'automne life avec les lunettes et
tagada tagada tintin tintin il faut plus
jamais que j'ai c'est de chanter
il faut absolument un regard louche donc
un mental et c'est quelqu'un qui a un
regard qui nous fait peur
et aussi qui doit être caché dans
l'ombre et ne laissait dépasser que son
ou ses mains pour nous manipuler vos
achats mais seulement si le chat un
regard louche était parti beaucoup trop
loin je pense que tu es parti du côté
des vaisseaux de la vierge marie les
vaisseaux spatiaux évidemment damien lui
normal qu'ils me voient comme à la casa
un pokémon au poker c'est le type qui
fait ce genre de tête et qui sait qu'il
a gagnée avant même d'avoir distribué
les cartes ce message de julien et
accompagner une photo je me suis dit
qu'on porte à gérer quand même pour
faire la photo
même moi j'aurais poste mais pour moi un
mentaliste est un fou qui n'arrête pas
de me le fais à chaque vidéo et qui je
pense a des pouvoirs reçu par des
vaisseaux de la vierge marie
c'est un élu pour tester les hommes et
leurs cerveaux florian qu on avait dit
qu'on n'en parlait pas de ça on avait
dit que ça restait entre toi moi et le
christ cosmique casse merlin
l'enchanteur d'un détecteur de mensonges
un jour de mer à l'esprit aiguisé à qui
tu ne vois pas croire que tu trouves ça
sous poireaux pommes de terre délicieuse
si c'est bon ça va paulette mais dont le
mental et se font dire que tu as un
problème à résoudre avec la soupe pommes
de terre poireaux de ta mère évident ou
alors avec des enfants qui ne veulent
jamais manger ta soupe pommes de terre
poireaux alors qu'il dise monsieur c'est
bon il est au dessus des dieux eux mêmes
au dessus des magiciens et puis ça vit
toujours en noir avec pense souvent
qu'il est énigmatique
alors qu'en fait il est ennuyeux là
aussi on sent le trauma julien david je
ne sais pas quel mentalist est venu à
ton anniversaire quand tu étais petit
mais à part un bon étaient traumatisés
ils se touchent le front avec un doigt
je sais pas ce qu'ils ont d'ailleurs
avec le triangle égaré ou les vagues
mais mon fils d'un an et arrêter les
écrivent une lettre par page a4
ces accords spectacle mais toujours une
lettre partage il se vend cher à prendre
le dico des livres chiant à la lettre
près par coeur mais les n'y aura pas j'y
passe ils servent de mémos à course
ils servent aussi de calculatrice
scientifique mais pas graphique ils ont
un regard froid et regarde le front en
avant la bouche constipé sur leurs
affiches qui connaissent la réponse
depuis depuis prennent un malin plaisir
mais dix minutes à la donne et on marque
un silence dès qu'un second tous les
trois gros sur la musique de qui veut
gagner des millions
ne font jamais d'erreur car les erreurs
sont prévus précise le numéro du loto
mais un pinceau le mentaliste n'avait
jamais gagné
le comble il espère avoir du monde à
leurs spectacles invités ils n'en savent
rien à la france aaa
willow comme la plupart des choses que
tu as mis sombre et permet moi d'aller
m'asseoir dans un coin de déprimés
pendant quelques jours aussi le prochain
mentale vlog ne sera que lundi prochain
pourquoi tu fais ce job alors que tu
peux jouer au loto tous les quatre
matins a gagné ta vie comme ça quand on
a affaire à un mentaliste je pense que
nous avons peur des des visages et
rapidement on peut se faire démasquer
lors d'un mensonge d'autres personnes
vont devenir paramo pensant que thil
carrément d'observer des gens le
mentaliste si on ne sait pas le travail
qu'il ya derrière peut être prise comme
un être plus intelligent que tous les
autres du coup ça me fait paraître hors
norme et il veut faire fantasmer des
femmes
on en revient quand même au fait qu'à
chaque fois ce sont les femmes qui
projette st je suis même d'ailleurs très
étonné bravo les mecs j'ai pas eu un
seul commentaire sur la drague sur les
manipulations envers les filles
ce que je retiens au final c'est
qu'apparemment j'ai un regard louche que
je sers de post-it portable de
calculatrices portable ça je le savais
déjà que vous avez peur que je manipule
que je dise dans vos pensées que je vous
met dans mon lit par amanda blank
j'achète un grand lit que je passe ma
vie à lire des trucs chiants c'est pas
tout à fait faux et c'est pas tout à
fait vrai c'est une question de point de
vue moi ce que je lis je le trouve pas
chiant et que je suis source de blagues
à base de fromage entre la fan page et
le profil sur facebook il ya eu plus de
200 messages comme ça vraiment ces coups
c'était un test en fait j'avais envie de
lancer des vidéos un peu plus
interactive et vidéos qu'on construirait
ensemble je sais pas trop si vous alliez
participé souvent vous me donnez des
thèmes dans les commentaires des vidéos
youtube ça c'est cool mais pour faire ce
genre de vidéos là je trouve quand même
que facebook c'est plus facile dans les
commentaires tout le monde et réunit
donc lundi vous poser une nouvelle
question est là j'adapterai je pense la
vidéo de jeudi en fonction de toutes vos
réponses 6 à boutons merci d'être ici si
ce genre de vidéos vous plaît vous
pouvez me le faire savoir en laissant un
petit pouce en l'air n'oubliez pas
également de vous abonner rendez vous
demain à 17 heures pour le prochain
mentale blog ciao